what do you think makes a great director
well for the longest time I was trying
to discern what that was I know I think
because they if you go on a set the kind
of sets that I like you you see
everybody working and you know the ADEs
like shouting out all the instructions
and doing this and that you know and the
whole movie is really taking place in
the directors head so for me to go on a
set and see what the directors process
is is almost impossible because if he's
done his job right then he's like he's
cast the actors and he's cast the crew
and when he gets to the set - except for
like steering the ship a little bit this
way or a little bit that way shouldn't
really be anything for him to do you
know he should be able to sit back and
let all these building blocks that he's
put together to come like before that
camera that day to let that happen now
there are a lot of directors that that's
not their style you know and also when I
am I I always seem to get myself
involved in projects that I don't have
enough time for so time becomes uh and
then I have to be very proactive and
okay the cameras coming here after that
you know so you can you can on those
kind of movies you can tell who the
director is but my my impression on
going on set with some of the great
directors is that you can't really see
what their process is it's so yeah it's
really hard to know what people's
process is except by the quality of
their product you know what do you think
of the cliche that some directors are
afraid of actors do you think that's
really true or do you think that some
people just operate
sort of being removed and letting them
do their thing and it gives the
appearance of fear well you know it's
funny because Kubrick has a reputation
of not really someone said I think that
he period he was a CGI animator he'd be
able to control every aspect of his
movie you know because he you're doing
it all pixel by pixel but and I think
some of his best movie performances that
he got were from an actor called Peter
Sellers and I'm sure he was enacted he
could just like wind up and start
shooting and right you know the
performance is there I think I think a
lot of inexperienced directors are
afraid of the star power of the actors
that they're that they're working with
so they you know they don't quite know
how to deal with that and I think a lot
of star power actors working with those
directors saying I'm not really getting
enough from you as a director so I want
to be directed you know so I thought I
think there's a lot of there's a lot of
layers going on there you know but if
you are afraid of your actors that's not
a helpful place to be because those
actors are your movie you know and I
don't like to give actors direction
I like that you know I've cast them I've
seen them in the thing and I'm I sit
back and I I want to see that
performance now if the summers not
working for me story wise well we you
know but but I'll never sit back in the
chair and and yell at the actor hey why
don't you do it this way you know it's a
you know for me Directioners I'll get up
out of my chair I'll go into the set
click the act with one side and we'll I
will have a very personal conversation
about it
[Music]
actors on your movie
you